après trois semaines d'école à la maison
pour certains tous les élèves ont pu
retrouver leurs salles de classe
depuis le déconfinement en raison d'un
protocole sanitaires strictes seuls 200
écoliers sur les 366 inscrits fréquenté
chaque semaine l'école romain rolland de
saint cyr l'école
désormais tout le monde peut être
accueillis en continuant malgré tout à
respecter quelques gestes barrières
chaque classe a un espace pour prendre
les récréations dans les classes on a
rajouté des tables comme on a pu pour
pouvoir garder un maximum de distance
entre les élèves
ça n'a pas toujours été possible donc il
n'ya pas toujours un mètres d'écart
entre chaque élève quand ils sont assis
dans la classe il se lave toujours les
mains en rentrant en classe en sortant
récréation en rentrant de récréation
avant de manger à la cantine
toutes les écoles élémentaires de saint
cyr l'école propose un service de
restauration le midi ainsi que le centre
de loisirs le soir une organisation
rendue possible grâce à la municipalité
la commune fournit jada hydroalcoolique
savons antibactériens aux logiques sur
les toilettes et et puis tous les
aménagements nécessaires qui sont les
les traçages au sol dans la cour dans
les couloirs de façon à pouvoir
permettre la distanciation ce matin
cette classe de cm2 comptait seulement
un absent alors que les grandes vacances
débutent dans moins de deux semaines
l'éducation nationale met en avant
plusieurs intérêts pédagogiques pour
cette reprise pour tous symboliquement
psychologiquement c'était important à la
fois de reprendre cette dynamique
globale on va dire normal d'une
pédagogie de classe entière et puis de
marquer cette transition finalement avec
avant l'été pour pouvoir s'imaginer se
projeter déjà dans la classe du niveau
supérieur l'année prochaine je pense
qu'il faut apprendre à vivre avec les
avec le co vide comme plein d'autres
maladies qui circulent plein d'autres
virus dans 7 établissements scolaires
près de 90 % des élèves sont retournés
en classe 22 juin